hey 42 here in Athens in the state of
Georgia there is a tree that owned
itself this trick is the only tree in
the world that had illegal land out of
the one it lives upon having fond
memories of the tree when growing up the
land owner William hated Jackson wanted
to protect the tree forever so in the
early 1800 he went to court and
transferred the deed for the London
8-foot radius around the tree from
himself to the tree to this day the
legality of the trees property rights
have never been questioned planet Earth
has 57 million square miles of land or
36 billion acres and until the day comes
when we set foot on other planets that's
all the land we have lands therefore is
the most limited commodity we have thus
it comes at a great price as the
population increases and more homes are
needed to house the next generation the
demand for land increases in the past
ten years alone one prices have traveled
in some countries but who owns the world
and I'm not talking about power or money
but the actual earth used to stand apart
from the wilds of Alaska to Mongolia who
really owns the dirt and gravel beneath
your feet and more importantly who owns
your house and the land it sits up if it
really you or is it in fact the bank the
government or some kind of London Gentry
let's start with America and its 2.3
billion acres of land across 50 states
the biggest landowner in America is
cable billionaire John Malone who owns a
staggering 2.2 million acres
he owns enormous ranches in Wyoming New
Mexico and Colorado oh he also owned
Hume wood castle in Ireland because he
thought it was pretty Malone is closely
followed by Ted Turner who owns 2
million acres of American land across
seven states he is a media mogul he
founded CNN Turner's land includes four
in ranches 28 homes and the world's
largest herd of privately owned bison he
also has four girlfriends he spends a
week with each one per month because if
you're a 78 year old billionaire who
owns a massive chunk of America then why
the hell not an Englishman's home is his
castle no matter how big or small your
humble abode is yours and no one could
ever take it away from you or can they
and come to think of it is it really
yours if you own your home buy a
leasehold then you have zero right to
the ownership of your property or it
slum absolutely not
you are simply renting the property and
have decided to pay for the next ninety
nine years rent of Thrones the
freeholder is the true owner of the land
and everything upon it he or she is your
landlord for the next ninety nine forty
years if you are wealthy enough to own a
flat or even a house in London then you
probably don't actually own it all the
lumps this guy does instead 26 year old
Hugh Grosvenor the seventh Duke of
Westminster who owns about half of
London he is worth over 12 billion
pounds making him the richest person
under 30 years old in the world and you
are simply renting from him for a very
very long time but what if you do own
the freehold to your property and what
have you paid off your mortgage with no
interference from the bank then you must
be the one true owner of your castle and
this land well not quite I'm sorry to
burst your dream of setting up your own
country in your back garden but you
don't truly own any land in fact not
many people do there's a centuries-old
doctrine of war called absolute land
ownership which is fuzzy at best but it
means that you may hold the right to a
piece of one and its title what you
don't absolutely own it
in most countries are government Oh
the entirety of the land in that country
all you own is the title to that one
giving you certain rights to it but not
absolute ownership and the government
can forcefully buy your house and land
off you under vicked you at any time if
for example they wish to build a bypass
through your home well you've got to
build bypasses this is true for every
country in the world after all
if the government didn't own 100% of the
land within that country and it wouldn't
really be a complete country now would
it it would be Spain - all these little
plots of land where people have
purchased property each property owner
would essentially own their own little
country and maps of the world would get
really really complicated so countries
just have to own 100% of their land in
order to create and enforce laws within
their boundaries but in truth there is
no such thing as outright true land
ownership the law surrounding land
owners have really messy and they change
completely depending on which country
you're in
in reality you have essentially paid for
some rights over a piece of land but
your right to the land are overlapped by
the rights of other bodies such as the
government and the monarchy if there is
one speaking of monarchies that's when
things get really complicated for
example in England the absolute
landowner is not the government's but
the crown an independent body who acts
on behalf of Her Majesty the Queen Queen
Elizabeth the second owned every square
inch of one of the United Kingdom when
you buy a property in the UK you are
simply put on a map called the Land
Registry to identify that you own the
title to that plot of lump in reality
you don't own the land
you hold it you are a tenant of the
crown if you were to really buy that
land outright then you would have to
draw up a sales contract between you Her
Majesty the Queen and the government you
have certain historic legal ties of the
crown but that would just be one less
place for Elizabeth
to drive her Land Rover and walk her
corgis so I don't think that going to
happen one element of the law that
exemplifies the fact that you don't
actually own your own land is that if
you strike oil on your private land in
the UK you have no right to it the crown
automatically owned any oil or other
valuable minerals found below private
properties and all you're entitled to is
compensation to replace the soil once
all the oil has been extracted and sold
for lots and lots of money none of which
you will ever see but the British Isles
is not all that Her Majesty the Queen
owns
far from it as a matter of fact queen
elizabeth ii it's a largest landowner in
the world by a large margin the queen
owns 1/6 of the Earth's land and she is
the only person in the world that owns
entire countries queen elizabeth ii owns
6.6 billion acres of one and she is
headed stages 16 countries collectively
known as the commonwealth realm she owns
the entire countries of canada and
australia which are the 2nd and 6th
largest countries in the world
respectively the queen's total land
holdings are worth an estimated 25
trillion pounds which makes her by a
considerable margin the wealthiest
person on the planet but it's not quite
as simple as that she is more of a
ceremonial owner of set countries while
she does technically own the land the
individual countries governments have
ownership of the titles of the lands and
they profit from it the crown doesn't
actually see any profit for much of its
land holdings because of this the
Queen's actual estimated wealth it's
somewhere around 275 million pounds I
mean that's not to be sniffed up but
it's rather measly for somebody who owns
1/6 of the planet excluding oceans she
also owns a drive-through McDonald's and
Slough because why not when you're
queen but symbolic or not she is
undoubtedly the world's largest
landholder so who then is following in
her footsteps well that would be King
Salman of Saudi Arabia who inherited the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia after the recent
death of his half-brother King Abdullah
he upped 553 million acres in total just
8 percent of what the Queen owns but
those 553 million acres are rich in oil
which gives the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia
a GDP of 646 billion dollars at number
three on the landowner list is none
other than Pope Francis the pump owns
the Vatican City which is its own nation
state but isn't the Vatican City also
the smallest country in the world
yes it most definitely is at just 108
acres so then how does that make the
Pope the world's third largest landowner
well the Roman Catholic Church actually
owns 177 million acres of land worldwide
which means that the Pope owns 177
million acres of land that of course
includes every one of their religious
institutions diocese and the Vatican own
embassy to the Holy See which are in 81
countries if all land was divided
equally between every person on the
planet then every single person would
own roughly five acres of one just over
three four pitches
but of course it is land ownership has
always been about power wealth and
social class and it's still every time
you mow your lawn you are imitating the
aristocrats of the past in a very
figurative sense of course because
wealthy aristocrats definitely didn't
mow their own lawns
you sit the reason that lawns were
invented in the first place was to show
up and demonstrate power it was a way of
saying hey look everyone we're so rich
we can afford to own and maintain vast
areas of land which we have no real
useful but look isn't it impressive with
shrubberies mazes and fountains yes lots
and lots of fountains in medieval times
100% of the land your average person
owned was used to either build upon and
live in or to grow food to feed your
family
most people would starve if they decided
to grow topiary instead of cabbages you
can't eat toe prick
I've tried so wealthy Kings princes
lords and ladies would purposely clear
all trees from their excessive areas of
unused ones and grow grass upon it
instead creating a meadow or lawn
this served two purposes firstly it was
now far easier to spot people trying to
invade their castle and secondly they
could now show off how much spare ones
they have lying around this was even
more impressive back then because of
course the lawnmower didn't exist neatly
trimmed grass lawn had to be
painstakingly cut by hand by servants
wielding signs and shears the Palace of
Versailles is a prime example of this
showy offering even with modern
gardening tools the amount of money time
and manpower that goes into maintaining
a garden this stunning is rather
impressive the trend of maintaining
lawns to impress of us have continued
throughout the centuries and although
the lawns have become significantly
smaller with ever-increasing population
your neighbor will probably still sneer
at it if you don't keep it nicely
trimmed because this medi
tradition has become ingrained within
our culture but who cares of its
exorbitant and completely unnecessary
you are the king of your castle and okay
you don't actually own your castle but
who cares get out there and mow your
lawn thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video then please click here to
support me on patreon which helps me to
make better videos and you can get some
pretty cool rewards you click here to
watch another video and if you haven't
already don't forget to subscribe